deputy president william ruto wants to
be kenya's next president
his main rival in the upcoming election
ryla odinga didn't show up for the
presidential candidate's debate
opinion polls show ryla has a lead over
ruto but there are still enough
undecided voters to swing it would
opinion polls give him a small lead over
you
opinion polls are opinion polls
we are here
ninth of august is around the corner
and
do not trust opinion force because
sometimes they are skewed and doctored
to feed a certain narrative
four candidates are running the main
contenders ruto and ryla were meant to
debate with each other politicians in
kenya are not held to account very often
and out on the campaign trail
presidential candidates get to deliver
their message to crowds of thousands of
people without being asked any questions
pro-democracy groups and the organizers
of this event hope that here on this
stage at least the candidates would hold
each other to account but half of the
candidates haven't showed up
i have tremendous respect so ruto was on
stage alone answering questions from the
moderators your opponent who did not
turn up tonight said you could not come
to this debate because he did not want
to face a man who has no regard for
ethics
public morals or shame
how do you respond to that
do you sincerely believe that that is
the reason why he's not here
ryla has the backing of outgoing
president uhuru kenyatta even though the
two were bitter rivals in past elections
and the backing of most of the
historical political establishment
that's dominated kenya ever since
independence from british colonial rule
out on the campaign trail both ryla and
ruto have been promising to spend money
to ease the soaring prices of food and
fuel
they've been less clear about how
they'll afford it how they'll tackle
kenya's record high levels of debt or
the widespread corruption that's
contributed to it they've both held
senior roles in previous governments
under which borrowing grew and stealing
of public funds was widespread
the debate was meant to give voters a
chance to find out more kenyan
politicians a
famously
exhibit impunity you know i i think it's
an important opportunity for
the public to hold
the presidential candidates accountable
to the propositions that they make their
manifestos are expensive they're
extremely ambitious
but
nobody understands how they're going to
implement those
the polls on the 9th of august may show
what difference ruto's appearance or
ryla's no-show have made on the
undecided voters
malcolm webb al jazeera nairobi kenya